أيوه.
طيب، لو تقدّمنا للأمام
الـ qubit هيكون الوحدة الحسابية الأساسية
اللي ممكن نتعامل بيها مع
المشاكل المعقدة في العالم
خلونا نحاول نفهم الفرق بينهم
وفين تيجي قوة الـ qubit
لو بصّينا على الجانب الشمال
دي طريقة لوصف الموضوع وهنستخدم الرسوم دي
طول التقديم عشان
نوضّح القوة — بنشوف دايرة
ونقطتين، لمّا النقطة تكون في القطب الشمالي
دي صفر، ولمّا تكون في القطب الجنوبي دي واحد
ده الـ bit الكلاسيكي بحالتيه، أمّا الـ qubit فهو
وحدة المعلومات في العالم الكمّي
وهنا بنلاقي الصورة أغنى
الكرة كلها صفر وواحد في نفس الوقت
وممكن يكون في حالة التراكب دي
عندنا حيلة خاصة متاحة لينا
مش بس ممكن نحطّهم في أي مكان على الكرة
تخيّل إن كل واحد منهم
زي قمر صغير
داخل الكرة وممكن ندوّر القمر ده
فهنا بتشوف إن
الكرة السفلية اتدوّرت شوية
عشان كده بتشوف لون أزرق بسيط
وبينفشي، وممكن ندوّرها لآخرها
فده مثلاً تدوير مية وتمانين درجة
يعني عندنا مفهوم الطوْر اللي الكم بيوفّره لينا
الكم بيعطي الـ qubit ثلاث قدرات خارقة
وهي قدرة التراكب
وقدرة التداخل
وقدرة التشابك
خلينا نفهمهم — مبدأ التراكب في الحقيقة
سهل الفهم جداً
فالكرة على الشمال
إمّا قطب شمالي صفر أو قطب جنوبي واحد
ولو جمعنا الحالتين دول
بقى عندنا qubit في حالة تراكب فيه الاتنين
صفر وواحد في نفس الوقت، شمال
وجنوب. الرسمة على اليمين نفس الحاجة
بس دلوقتي هنعمل حيلة صغيرة
هنطبّق gate — quantum gate
واللي عملناه هنا، اتفضّل
قدرنا نغيّر، يعني قدرنا
ندوّر الأقمار الصغيرة دي صح؟
فدوّرناها مية
وتمانين درجة وبقى عندنا واحد
فلمّا بنجمع صفر زائد واحد دلوقتي بنطلع
بحالة تراكب
بس لاحظ إنها مختلفة
في الشمال صفر وواحد
لسّه صفر وواحد بس دلوقتي بحالة مدوّرة
للواحد، وده هيكون قوي جداً
عشان نستغل حاجة تانية مثيرة جداً وهي
مبدأ التداخل
وده عملية مش موجودة في عالم الـ bit الكلاسيكي
فهنا في المثال ده عندنا
صفر وواحد على الشمال زائد
الحالة الجديدة اللي عملناها
وهي كمان صفر وواحد
بس مع القمر المدوّر ده، لمّا بنعمل كده
بنخلّي الحالتين تتداخل
ولاحظ حاجة مثيرة جداً حصلت
ألغينا حالة الواحد
وطلعنا بحالة الصفر بس
عملنا ده عن طريق تداخل الحالات
فالفرصة الجاية اللي عندنا دلوقتي
هي: قد إيه حالة ممكن نعملها؟
والجميل في الكم إننا ممكن نعمل عدد أُسّي
من الحالات، خلينا نبص على نظام عنده
خمس qubit، هنا بنصوّر الـ qubit دول
كـ qubit مستقلة، شايفهم على الشمال
أصفار وواحدات وبتتضاعف، عندنا خمسة
منهم، فعدد الحالات اللي ممكن نعملها في الـ
quantum computer اللي بنصوّره على الكرة على اليمين
هو اتنين أُس
عدد الـ qubit اللي عندنا، وهنا هو خمسة
فاتنين أُس خمسة يساوي اتنين وتلاتين حالة
يعني بنشوف اتنين وتلاتين قمر صغير
لاحظ إننا في الحالة دي ما اعتبرناش
أي طوْر، كلهم بينفشي. الجانب القوي في
استخدام خاصية التشابك في العالم الكمّي
هو إننا ممكن نعمل دلوقتي حالات
زي اللي بنشوفها على اليمين
فيها مزيج من البينفشي
والأزرق، والحالة دي ما تقدرش توصفها
كحاصل ضرب مستقل لـ
الـ qubit الخمسة دول
وبما إن عندنا اتنين وتلاتين حالة
ده بيقولنا حاجة عميقة جداً